alright next question is from a user is
this also Twitter Louis i'm most likely
yeah a borrow what have been asked i
have no idea if that's how it's
pronounced right a borrow with happiness
wants to know what's the best concert
you guys have ever been to Louis have
you before I've been to more concerts
than me if you include sort of like
local bands right yeah cuz I've been to
war how many did I play in I mean yeah
countless yeah so I have been to I I
wouldn't there have been a few of those
that were a lot of fun and I still
wouldn't count those among the top
concerts I've been to ah but I so i'll
let you answer this one first wow well i
still remember one of the first concerts
i went to was tonic and the goo goo
dolls and that just still sticks in my
mind because it was basically my first
concert experience it was two bands that
had a lot of songs that i like to that
still in my mind they were huge that
they were they were very big then I've
seen the police sting in the police
twice very very good shows although I i
love sting in the police's music but
I've seen them in these huge venues
where it's somewhat impersonal you're
basically listening to amplifiers and
you're very very far away I don't know I
mean that I love the music with the
experience wasn't completely the best
I've been to a bunch of matisyahu shows
and as you know Louis were friends with
Stu was mighty I was bassist and also
bassist in dub trio etcetera they've put
on awesome shows over the years recently
I went to a show where they actually
open for 3 11 and 3 11 is a band that
I've loved since I was I don't know in
middle school or high school or whatever
it was really great to see them uh and
then recently I also this is just a
random thing i found out that this
argentinian reggae band called los
pericos were playing in Boston and it's
a band I'd sort of been into a little
bit casually over the years went to see
them amazing show I mean just very good
instrumentalists and they sounded great
it was a smaller venue and it was
fantastic those are some of my concert
highlights i guess i have it at a
definitive number one better I've ever
been to was it brutal uh it was it was
brutal yeah yeah it was I at the
Palladium in in Worcester worcester
massachusetts was to Massachusetts this
is a a very large venue uh now the
downstairs is
the big venue there's a small upstairs
venue this was in the downstairs it's
it's very large big floor no seats lots
of metal shows here so this was a metal
show and devin townsend opened for
Gojira right and this was maybe the
first time that Gojira was actually the
the headliner on a US tour are you
serious oh yeah I'm serious okay and uh
everybody was just as into devin
townsend as they were good era it was
the biggest mosh pit I've ever seen in
my life okay um the arms were flailing
the armed arms the Eyres it was nuts and
uh the sound was fantastic which almost
never happens at the Palladium uh it
sounded great and it was just totally
totally epic and I've never seen anyone
command a crowd like devin townsend
anything he said to do the entire place
did it uh with no hesitation right had
had he told them to to jump off a bridge
stripped bare they probably would have
all done that to ya all right that
sounds cool another one I went to that
that was really great was third eye
blind but again this is because these
bands were bands I liked there's a lot
written about how the bands you like
when you're usually like 13 to 18 remain
as the bands you like the most later in
life as well uh and these are bands that
I sort of got into it that time out
green day you know the green day yet you
could say what everyone about green day
uh the band I liked at that time put on
very good show enjoyed hearing all the
hits etcetera yeah there's a lot of
truth to that I mean I grew up listening
to a lot of Alison chain Soundgarden
bush I still love those bands i still
listen to them yes just uh well little
trickier to see them in concert these
days I'll say yeah